I hope they remember you
I don't pick lint amen
clearly retirement doesn't suit you hey
everybody like the clip says everybody's
wondering what the deal with Hawkeye is
in infinity war we haven't seen him in
any of the trailers we've seen him on
the set of Avengers 4 so what is going
on the directors have issued a couple
comments so because this is one of the
biggest comments on my infinity war
trailer video yesterday I wanted to do a
video for the missing characters in
infinity war so far now there are a lot
of characters that have been confirmed
they just have not appeared in the
trailers yet the directors have talked
about most of them if you're brand new
to my channel there's an Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway that's still
going on all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
the video so starting with Hawkeye the
thing the directors said about his
presence in these movies is that he has
his own journey
meaning that he spends most of the time
not with any of these Avengers teams
which is probably the number one reason
why he's not in any of these trailers
the thing about putting trailers
together is it's meant to be an ad for
the movie so his fans like we're already
going to see the movie the trailers are
mostly to get people who don't know
about Avengers to go see the movie like
your mom your grandma maybe people
who've been living under rocks for the
last 10 years so there's like a time
limit for the amount of footage they can
cram into these so they just want to
give you all the big money shots without
spoiling everything
which is why you get scenes with Robert
Downey jr. meeting the guardians of the
galaxy because there's like four
characters on screen there and most of
them are the biggest most popular
characters from The Avengers so I would
be willing to bet that Hawkeye just does
not have a ton of screen time and he's
been doing the same thing as Captain
America Black Widow and Falcon Secret
Avengers style business on his own
because Hawkeye's wife is listed in the
IMDB credits meaning that they probably
tagged her or Hawkeye senses that
something really bad is coming so he
goes to armor up but he still really
hates Tony Stark like he was one of the
people that was ready to kill him when
Tony came to the raft and it's gonna
take something major like the death of
one of their friends in order to bring
him back to the squad
so Hawkeye Ronin during these movies
Ronan meaning that he's a rogue samurai
by himself
not on one of these teams is probably
why you don't see him in any of these
shots the trailer yesterday was mostly
about the big pairings like oh my god
characters together on screen that you
never thought would be together next big
missing characters are ant-man in the
wasp you know probably the second big
question that I got where are they does
it connect to infinity war what's going
on with their movie when cap needed help
if I'd asked you would you have come I
guess we'll never know
so the Russos actually weren't able to
say a ton about the movie ant-man and
the wasp
not just the characters but the movie
itself because it hasn't happened yet so
they didn't want to give any spoilers
but they say that does lead into
infinity war so like what is ant-man's
big thing he grows really big and he
shrinks really small what I'm hoping is
is that they use that ability to go down
into the soul world of the soul stone
during Avengers 4 but they're not major
characters during infinity warp so Iron
Man probably wouldn't reach out to him
to bring him into the fold until they
needed his ability like hey we need
somebody who can achieve this task that
we have to do but for the most part and
this will also be true for Captain
Marvel when I talk about her next is is
that they'll be characters that they'll
tag during infinity war when the
directors try to talk around characters
like they don't flat-out just tell you
exactly where they pop up it's probably
because they have very little screen
time and even Evangeline Lilly confirmed
that she's not an infinity war so if
anybody from Team ant-man shows up
during infinity war it's probably just a
brief tag for ant-man to sort of provide
some connective tissue to what's
happening during his movie moving on to
Captain Marvel next really big character
the directors have said some official
stuff about her just because it's a much
bigger conversation that's going on
because we haven't seen a version of her
and the MCU yet so everyone's like when
is she gonna show up the directors said
that she is not in infinity war what
they did not say though is is that you
will not see her when you go to see that
movie so what I'm thinking is is because
she's such a big concept that she'll get
some sort of post-credit scene that will
tee up the idea of her character without
flat-out showing you what's going on
so like Nick Fury Maria Hill also
missing characters but they're in the
Captain Marvel movie Nick Fury or
somebody from shield one of those
characters probably has some sort of
post-credits tag where they probably set
up the idea that she's coming in
Avengers four they did confirmed that
she will appear during Avengers four of
course because her movies sort of
introduces her character officially then
she becomes a big Avengers character
during Avengers four but again like they
said she's not in the movie meaning
she's not in the body of the movie so
like at the beginning they learn about
Thanos they try to fight him he kicks
their ass there's a big battle in
Wakanda he probably gets the mind gem
from vision maybe he has the other gems
with him then you get all your post
credits scenes the sort of tag Avengers
for Captain Marvel stuff anything really
big that they want to tee up next big
character is Peter Dinklage
so biggest rumor right now is that he is
actually playing the king of the dwarves
so he shows up during this team Thor
scene where Thor forges his new
Stormbreaker weapon where he lifts it
towards the sky and it gives off all
this lightning so it's possible that
he's standing somewhere in the
background of this scene here and they
just digitally removed him but as four
story remains to be seen I'm just
expecting them to tee up the history of
Mjolnir and where a lot of those really
awesome Asgardian weapons came from the
dwarves are the people that create all
the coolest weapons in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they're also the same
people that Forge the Infinity Gauntlet
that Thanos puts all the gems in so if
you're wondering where the actual
gauntlet came from the physical one that
he wears on his hand that came from the
dwarves
so RPG style when you're farming for
legendaries that's where you go to do it
speaking of team Thor people asking
about Heimdall so I think you know this
also kind of throws out the idea of
Heimdall having the soul gem but he is
on this as guardianship so there's a
whole bunch of scenes that they cut out
and put into different parts of this
last big trailer you see Thor getting
his head squeezed like a grape probably
gets thrown into outer space
you see Proxima midnight holding her
spear right up to Loki's head so this is
probably right after Theo stakes the
tesseract and smashes it so that he can
get the space gem out so there's a small
chance I mean it's not confirmed or
anything like that still speculation
that both Loki it Heimdall died during
this opening scene here and Thor's left
to float in the vacuum of space after
Hook's somehow gets ported back probably
with the tesseract to earth to crash
through the sanctum most of the other
characters that are missing right now
are minor characters associated with the
a list Avengers so you have like Everett
Ross Nick Fury Maria Hill Aunt May in
Pepper Potts most of them might get
brief tags like there might be a very
brief Aunt May seemed like hey I'm going
on a field trip and then you get all
these crazy events then he comes back
after don't tell Aunt May like there's a
couple scenes that reference her but I
don't expect her to get a ton of scenes
during these next two Avengers films
spider-man 2 like the spider-man sequel
takes place in the moments right after
Avengers 4 so that's really where you're
gonna get all your Aunt May like guess
what just happened there'll be some sort
of attack at the beginning of that film
where they address all the craziness
that Peter's been through is for Pepper
Potts I've talked a little bit about
Iron Man's arc at the beginning of
infinity war it's really Doctor Strange
that calls into the sanctum to alert him
to what's going on so he's like oh they
had their Sherlock bros moment there's
probably some brief Pepper Potts tag
before he goes to the sanctum and that's
the last you see of her till Avengers 4
because she's been seen on set for
Avengers 4 supposedly in a suit of her
own armor so like a lot of these minor
characters that only get tagged during
infinity war will get bigger scenes
during Avengers 4 so that also includes
like ant-man and the wasp obviously
Captain Marvel
so Hawkeye another one of those
characters that probably doesn't get a
bunch of scenes till Avengers 4 but let
me know in the comments if you feel like
I left any of the big characters out of
this video I just tried to do the
biggest ones but obviously there's like
a crazy long list of people that will
get referenced of course I'll be posting
all kinds of infinity war videos in the
next couple of months so make sure you
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss any of the videos and I'll
announce the winner from this video when
I post new Marvel but congratulations to
the winner from my last big video Grady
please private message me on my channel
so I can get your details click here to
rewatch the infinity war trailer a
billion more times and click here for
that brand new run the jewels Rick and
Morty music video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]